Hey friends, it's Jillian from the teach me how to add all podcast if like me you're looking to travel more this year and make Some extra income on the side. This one is for you We've teamed up with Airbnb to share more about how to be an Airbnb host because you could be sitting in the perfect Airbnb spot right now if you have a spare bedroom Which also side note is such a fun way to meet new people from around the world if you're hosting them Why not make some extra money off of it? Or if you're always traveling like I am it's so easy to just Airbnb your whole place I was out of town for four months out of the year last year with a vacant condo Just sitting there not being used and I've realized how easy it would be to make extra money in the side to cover all of my
嘿，朋友们，我是“教你怎么做所有事”播客的吉莉安。如果你像我一样，希望今年能多去旅行，并赚点外快，那这期节目就是为你准备的。我们与爱彼迎（Airbnb）合作，分享更多关于如何成为爱彼迎房东的资讯。因为如果你有一间空置的卧室，你现在可能正坐在完美的爱彼迎房源里。顺便一提，接待来自世界各地的新人是一件非常有趣的事，为什么不通过这种方式赚点外快呢？或者，如果你像我一样经常旅行，把整套房子在爱彼迎上出租是如此简单。去年一年中有四个月我都不在城里，公寓空置着也没人住，我意识到在副业上赚点外快来支付我的全部
Travel costs when I'm away just by becoming an Airbnb host when I'm traveling the world I almost exclusively stay in Airbnb's because I like having access to a kitchen Feeling like I'm at home when I'm traveling having all the stuff that you would normally have when you're at home And I love the local recommendation guides that a lot of hosts provide So you can just get to know the area that you're visiting from someone who's actually lived in it I just used Airbnb actually into loom to stay at truly the most luxurious penthouse loft I have I've ever seen it was Such a vibe the aesthetic was incredible the service was fantastic and I loved the privacy of it
旅行费用是多么容易，只需在我周游世界时成为一名爱彼迎房东。当我旅行时，我几乎只住爱彼迎，因为我喜欢可以使用厨房，旅行时有在家的感觉，拥有你在家里通常会拥有的所有东西。我非常喜欢许多房东提供的当地推荐指南，这样你就可以通过一个真正在这里生活过的人来了解你正在访问的地区。事实上，我最近在图卢姆使用爱彼迎入住了一个我见过最奢华的顶层阁楼。那里的氛围太棒了，美学令人惊叹，服务好得没话说，而且我非常喜欢它的私密性。
Airbnb is such a smart way to use what you already have to generate more income Whether you're saving for a wedding or a big trip somewhere or just trying to cover bills and possibly bump up your income Your home might be worth more than you think so find out how much at Airbnb.ca slash host Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents if you feel at any time you need support Please contact your local crisis center for suggested phone numbers for confidential support Please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website Don't walk down a lonely German street particularly at night If you do you might feel something heavy jump on your back weighing you down
爱彼迎是利用现有资源产生更多收入的绝佳方式。无论你是在为婚礼、一次大旅行攒钱，还是只是想支付账单并可能增加收入，你的家可能比你想象的更有价值，访问 airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。我们的节目涉及严重且通常令人痛苦的事件。如果你在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心获取建议的保密支持电话号码。请在你的应用程序上或我们的网站上查看本集节目的节目说明。不要走在一条冷清的德国街道上，特别是在晚上。如果你这样做，你可能会觉得有什么重物跳上你的背，把你往下压。
You can't shake off the creature nor can you kill it? According to German folklore the Alphocker meaning leap upon is a mythological Shapeshifter that will hang on to you until you pass away from exhaustion or terror Variants to the legend say that the Alphocker kills its victims by tearing out their throats It can take the form of a goblin or a sad old lady and in some cases no shape at all The Alphocker can never be caught changing shape as it pleases and disappearing into the night It is said that church bells, sunlight, prayer and profuse swearing may help to ward off the evil creature Another version of the Alphocker lies in the legend of a beautiful young woman who prayed upon a
你既甩不掉这个生物，也无法杀死它？根据德国民间传说，“Alphocker”（意为“扑上来”）是一种神话中的形体变形者，它会一直缠着你，直到你因精疲力竭或惊恐而死。该传说的变体称，“Alphocker”通过撕开受害者的喉咙来杀死他们。它可以化身为小妖精或悲伤的老妇人，在某些情况下甚至没有固定的形体。人们永远抓不到“Alphocker”随心所欲地改变形体并消失在夜色中。据说，教堂钟声、阳光、祈祷和大量的咒骂可能有助于驱赶这个邪恶的生物。关于“Alphocker”的另一个版本在于一个美丽年轻女子的传说，她在一天工作结束后，扑向一个
border guard returning home after a long day at work He spotted the woman and as he approached was attacked from behind by a force that he could not see nor fight off The guard struggled and screamed before the attack suddenly ceased The beautiful woman disappeared leaving the guard to wonder if he had even seen her at all Although the legend of the Alphocker was derived from roots buried deep in German mythology a real life shapeshifter struck throughout Europe in the early 90s So pervasive was this woman who became known as the woman without a face that she traveled through multiple countries and murdered recklessly without ever being seen
在回家路上的边防警卫。他发现了这个女子，当他走近时，遭到了一股他既看不见也无法抗拒的力量从背后袭击。警卫挣扎着尖叫，随后袭击突然停止。美丽的女子消失了，留下警卫纳闷自己是否真的见过她。尽管“Alphocker”的传说源自深深扎根于德国神话的根基，但一个现实生活中的形体变形者在90年代初席卷了整个欧洲。这个被称为“无脸女子”的人如此无孔不入，以至于她穿梭于多个国家，肆无忌惮地杀人却从未被看到过。
She vanished every time leaving few clues behind to mark her presence Leesalotta Schlanger was going about her morning as usual on May 23, 1993 The 62 year old retired church warden lived alone in the German town of Eder-Ulberstein 700 kilometers south west of Berlin Leesalotta made some lemon cakes and placed them in the oven to cook in preparation for any house guests that might visit On her kitchen table lay a bouquet of flowers tied neatly together with metal wire Three days later, Leesalotta's neighbor arrived at her home to chat over a cup of tea She knocked on the front door
她每次都消失得无影无踪，几乎没有留下任何线索来证明她曾经出现过。1993年5月23日，莉萨洛塔·施兰格（Leesalotta Schlanger）像往常一样开始她的早晨。这位62岁退休的教堂看守独自住在距离柏林东南700公里的德国埃德尔-乌尔贝尔施泰因小镇。莉萨洛塔做了一些柠檬蛋糕并把它们放进烤箱烘烤，以备任何可能来访的做客亲友。在她的厨房桌子上，放着一束用金属丝整齐捆绑在一起的花束。三天后，莉萨洛塔的邻居来到她家串门喝茶。她敲了敲前门。
There was no answer Finding away inside, the neighbor came across Leesalotta's body on the floor Flowers littered the kitchen table Around Leesalotta's neck was the metal wire that had been used to bind them She had been strangled with such force that the wire was embedded into her throat The brutality of the murder coupled with the strength needed to overpower the victim and inflict her injuries led police to assume that Leesalotta's killer was a man A thorough examination of the crime scene uncovered little in the way of evidence The wire was common, available for purchase from many hardware stores
无人应答。邻居设法进入屋内，在地板上发现了莉萨洛塔的尸体。花束散落在厨房桌子上。在莉萨洛塔的脖子上，缠着曾用来捆绑它们的金属丝。她被勒得如此用力，以至于金属丝都嵌入了她的喉咙。谋杀的残酷性，加上制服受害者并造成其受伤所需的巨大力量，让警方认为莉萨洛塔的凶手是一名男性。对犯罪现场的彻底检查几乎没有发现什么证据。这种金属丝很常见，可以在许多五金店买到。
No foreign fingerprints or footprints were left behind by the killer While left unharmed, Leesalotta's Yorkshire terrier didn't make a peep around the time of the attack, which occurred on the morning she was found or the day prior This led to speculation that Leesalotta knew her killer or otherwise welcomed them inside, unsuspecting of any danger Several items were taken into evidence including a brightly coloured floral teacup that was sitting out in Leesalotta's kitchen A neighbour reported who they thought resembled a salesman leaving Leesalotta's
凶手没有留下任何外来的指纹或脚印。虽然毫发无伤，但莉萨洛塔的约克夏梗犬在袭击发生时（即她被发现的当天早晨或前一天）没有发出一点声音。这引发了一种猜测：莉萨洛塔认识凶手，或者以其他方式欢迎他们进入室内，对任何危险毫无防备。几件物品被作为证据带走，其中包括放在莉萨洛塔厨房里的一只色彩鲜艳的花卉茶杯。一名邻居报告说，在发现尸体前的几天里，看到一个他们认为是推销员的人离开莉萨洛塔的
house in the days before her body was found He was carrying a pilot's case and had a bodybuilder-like figure Detectives focused on this lead, but the man was never identified Eight years passed and Leesalotta Schlanger's murder remained unsolved On March 26, 2001, 61-year-old Yosef Valsumbach was alone at his home in Freiburg in Brysgau, 300km south of where Leesalotta Schlanger was murdered Yosef lived alongside a small shop where he dealt antiques Hearing a knock at the door, Yosef opened it and let the person on his doorstep inside
房子。他提着一个飞行员箱，身材像健美运动员。侦探们将重点放在这条线索上，但该男子从未被确认身份。八年过去了，莉萨洛塔·施兰格的谋杀案仍然未破。2001年3月26日，61岁的约瑟夫·瓦尔松巴赫（Yosef Valsumbach）独自在位于弗赖堡布赖斯高（Freiburg in Breisgau，距离莉萨洛塔·施兰格被杀地点以南300公里）的家中。约瑟夫住在一个经营古董的小店旁。听到敲门声，约瑟夫打开门，让门前的人进了屋。
As he turned his back, Yosef was hit over the head multiple times with a heavy object Police later found Yosef Valsumbach's body on the floor of his home In addition to having his skull broken, Yosef had also been strangled with a piece of garden wire €125 had been stolen from him A foreign DNA profile was found on Yosef's body, presumed to have come from his killer The same profile was also uncovered in his kitchen on a glass and in Yosef's antique shop adjacent to his house Sampling found on the sign in the shop window indicated that the killer had been brazen enough
当他转过身时，约瑟夫头部多次遭到重物袭击。警方后来在约瑟夫·瓦尔松巴赫家中的地板上找到了他的尸体。除了头骨碎裂外，约瑟夫还被一截园艺金属丝勒死。125欧元被偷了。在约瑟夫的遗体上发现了一个外国人的DNA谱系，推测来自他的凶手。同样的DNA谱系也在他厨房的一个玻璃杯中以及约瑟夫紧邻其住所的古董店里被发现。店面窗户招牌上的采样表明，凶手胆大妄为到
to turn it from open to closed after carrying out the murder The DNA profile was run through Germany's national DNA database As it was still in its infancy, the database did not locate a match However, the sample was uploaded in the hope of one day identifying Yosef's killer The sample itself was particularly intriguing While it was suspected that Yosef's killer was a male, the DNA proved otherwise It had come from a woman of Eastern European ancestry Although separated by almost a decade, the similarities between the murders of Lieselotte
在实施谋杀后将其从“营业”翻转为“暂停”。该DNA谱系被输入德国的国家DNA数据库。由于当时该数据库尚处于初期阶段，数据库没有找到匹配项。然而，该样本被上传，寄希望于有朝一日能确定约瑟夫凶手的身份。样本本身非常耐人寻味。虽然怀疑约瑟夫的凶手是男性，但DNA证明并非如此。它来自一名具有东欧血统的女性。尽管相隔近十年，莉萨洛塔·
Schlanger and Yosef Valsumbach were obvious Both were aged in their 60s, lived alone, and were strangled by wire Evidence taken from Lieselotte's house was re-examined following Yosef's murder A residual saliva sample from an unknown source was found on the floral teacup taken from her kitchen When compared to the sample on file from Yosef Valsumbach's murder, there was a match The same unknown woman of Eastern European ancestry was present at both crime scenes After following up nearly 3,000 leads, authorities were unable to identify the woman As with Lieselotte Schlanger's case, the investigation into the murder of Yosef Valsumbach went nowhere
施兰格和约瑟夫·瓦尔松巴赫谋杀案之间的相似之处显而易见。两人都在60多岁，独居，并被金属丝勒死。在约瑟夫被谋杀后，从莉萨洛塔家中提取的证据被重新检查。在从她厨房拿走的花卉茶杯上发现了一个来源不明的残留唾液样本。当与约瑟夫·瓦尔松巴赫谋杀案档案中的样本进行比对时，发现匹配。同一个身份不明、具有东欧血统的女性出现在两个犯罪现场。在跟进近3000条线索后，当局仍未能确定该女子的身份。正如莉萨洛塔·施兰格的案子一样，对约瑟夫·瓦尔松巴赫谋杀案的调查也陷入了死胡同。
Over the following months, the mysterious woman went on a crime spree throughout Germany In August 2001, police linked her DNA to several break-in-anners of garden sheds, 200 kilometers northeast of where Yosef was murdered A month later, a caravan was broken into a further 200 kilometers north The wanted woman's saliva was found on a half-eaten biscuit One month after the caravan break-in, a 7-year-old boy was walking near his home, 175 kilometers west, in the town of Gerlestone He stepped on a used syringe on a pathway, obtaining a needle-stick injury The boy was taken to hospital and tested for the transmissible diseases HIV and hepatitis Results came back negative
在随后的几个月里，这名神秘女子在整个德国展开了一系列犯罪活动。2001年8月，警方将她的DNA与距离约瑟夫被害地点东北200公里处的几起花园棚屋入室盗窃案联系起来。一个月后，一辆房车在更北200公里的地方遭到破门盗窃。这名通缉女子的唾液在一个吃了一半的饼干上被找到。在房车盗窃案发生一个月后，一名7岁男孩在西边175公里的盖尔斯通（Gerlestone）镇的家附近散步。他在小路上踩到了一支用过的注射器，导致针刺伤。男孩被送到医院，并接受了艾滋病毒和肝炎等传染病检测。结果呈阴性。
The syringe contained trace amounts of heroin and a minute sample of blood Test results revealed that the blood contained the same DNA profile as the woman who was suspected of murdering Lieselotte Schlanger and Yosef Valsumbach, as well as breaking into garden sheds and a caravan It seemed as though she was an intravenous drug user, with the need to fund her heroin addiction offering a possible motive for her crimes Without any further clues to hint at her identity, she was henceforth known as The Woman Without a Face Over one year passed, with no further crimes occurring that could be linked to the woman
注射器含有微量的海洛因和微量的血液。测试结果显示，血液中含有与涉嫌谋杀莉萨洛塔·施兰格和约瑟夫·瓦尔松巴赫以及闯入花园棚屋和房车的女子相同的DNA谱系。她似乎是一名静脉吸毒者，需要资助她的海洛因瘾，这为她的罪行提供了一个可能的动机。由于没有任何进一步的线索暗示她的身份，她此后被称为“无脸女子”。一年多过去了，再也没有发生可以与无脸女子联系起来的犯罪活动。
without a face Then, in 2003, she re-emerged 220 kilometers east of where her used syringe was found in Gerlestone lies the bustling town of Dietzenbach On New Year's Day 2003, Dietzenbach police were called to a break-in at a downtown office building Nothing much was stolen aside from some loose change However, DNA recovered from the crime scene matched The Woman Without a Face She had returned after 15 months of inaction A high-profile prosecutor who liaised with the police spoke of the Dietzenbach break-in, telling reporters It was a professional job, she left no fingerprints, but she did leave a scraping of skin and that
然后，在2003年，她再次现身。在距离盖尔斯通发现她用过的注射器以东220公里处，坐落着繁华的小镇迪岑巴赫（Dietzenbach）。2003年元旦，迪岑巴赫警方接到报警，称市中心一处办公大楼发生了一起入室盗窃案。除了散乱的零钱外，没有偷走太多东西。然而，从犯罪现场恢复的DNA与“无脸女子”相符。在经历了15个月的沉寂后，她又回来了。一位与警方保持联络的高调检察官谈到了迪岑巴赫的入室盗窃案，他告诉记者：这是一次专业的操作，她没有留下指纹，但她留下了一片皮屑，而这
was enough to pin the job on her A year later, in 2004, The Woman Without a Face's DNA was found yet again This time on a spring-loaded rifle used by a man to carry out a robbery in France It appeared that she was on the move across Europe But, by May 2005, she was back in Germany Earlier that month, a nomadic Romani man named Randolph attempted to shoot and kill his brother Police located the gun used by Randolph in the Rhine River which winds its way through the city of Worms DNA on a bullet was a match to The Woman Without a Face Worms was in close proximity to some of her previous crimes Randolph was arrested and charged with attempted murder
足以将这起案件定在她头上。一年后的2004年，“无脸女子”的DNA再次被发现。这一次是在一名男子在法国实施抢劫时使用的一把弹簧步枪上。看来她一直在欧洲各地流窜。但是，到2005年5月，她又回到了德国。同年早些时候，一个名叫伦道夫（Randolph）的游牧罗姆人试图开枪杀死他的兄弟。警方在蜿蜒穿过沃尔姆斯（Worms）市的莱茵河中找到了伦道夫使用的枪支。一颗子弹上的DNA与“无脸女子”相匹配。沃尔姆斯与她先前的某些罪行发生地距离很近。伦道夫被捕并被控谋杀未遂。
He testified that the gun had been given to him by his father years earlier He could not think of how any woman could be connected to the firearm and its bullets in any way Detectives believed Randolph and The Woman frequented the same Bohemian community even if they didn't know one another or interact directly This explained how and why she moved back and forth across Europe and had ties to everywhere she visited but never seemed to settle down in one spot for long A year later, 120km away in the German town of Zabrucken, an apartment was broken into Neighbours witnessed the offender enter the property and were able to provide a description
他作证说，这把枪是多年前他父亲给他的。他怎么也想不出任何女性会与这把枪及其子弹有任何联系。侦探们相信伦道夫和这名女子经常出入同一个波希米亚社群，即使他们并不认识彼此或直接互动。这就解释了她如何在欧洲各地来回穿梭，并与她访问过的每个地方都有联系，但似乎从未在一个地方安定下来太久。一年后，在120公里外的德国萨布鲁肯（Zabrucken）小镇，一间公寓遭到入室盗窃。邻居目睹了罪犯进入该物业，并能够向
to Police It was a man with short brown hair, dark eyes, a large nose and a thin vertical line of facial hair that ran from his lower lip to his chin Police were stunned when DNA uncovered at the crime scene came back as a positive match to The Woman Without a Face This revelation provided a possible answer as to why they had been so unsuccessful in tracking her down Investigators now suspected that their target identified as a man or donned a male disguise A police spokesperson told the BBC We can't rule out that our suspect is a man now or that she looks like a man We just don't know
警方提供描述。那是一个留着短棕色头发、深色眼睛、大鼻子、从下巴一直延伸到嘴唇下方有一条细细的垂直胡须的男子。当犯罪现场发现的DNA被证明与“无脸女子”完美匹配时，警方惊呆了。这一发现为一个可能的问题提供了答案：为什么他们在追踪她时如此不成功。调查人员现在怀疑，他们的目标自称为男性或进行了男性伪装。警方发言人告诉BBC：我们现在不能排除我们的嫌疑人是一个男人，或者她看起来像个男人。我们只是不知道。
Later that year, The Woman's DNA was discovered yet again, this time in the Austrian village of Mauthausen Like previous robberies, this one targeted a store In this case, The Woman had accomplices A gang of robbers set off an explosive device under a manhole cover near a large shopping centre The blast caused the windows of an electronic store to shatter, allowing the group to enter the premises and steal mobile phones before fleeing Though DNA belonging to The Woman Without a Face was found at the crime scene, no other foreign samples were found One of the gang members was eventually arrested for the robbery,
同年晚些时候，“无脸女子”的DNA再次被发现，这次是在奥地利毛特豪森（Mauthausen）村。和先前的抢劫案一样，这次的目标也是一家商店。在这个案件中，“无脸女子”有同伙。一伙劫匪在一个大型购物中心附近的一个人孔盖下引爆了爆炸装置。爆炸导致一家电子商店的玻璃窗碎裂，使该团伙得以进入店面并在逃跑前偷走手机。尽管在犯罪现场发现了属于“无脸女子”的DNA，但没有发现其他外来样本。其中一名团伙成员最终因这起抢劫案被捕，
but denied any knowledge of The Woman and wouldn't offer any further information that could lead to her identity She had somehow coerced or threatened her co-offenders to stay silent Michelle Kiesewetter grew up in the small German town of Uwe Weisbach, 350km southwest of Berlin Upon finishing school, Michelle joined the police force She started training at age 19 and once completed, joined the anti-terror unit of the German federal police By age 22, Michelle was stationed in Heilbronn, a historic city close to where The Woman Without a Face was known to strike In April 2007, Michelle Kiesewetter was a drug squad officer working undercover On the 25th, she was on duty, driving her green
但否认认识该女子，并且不肯透露任何可能导致确认她身份的进一步信息。她不知何故胁迫或威胁了她的同案犯保持沉默。米歇尔·基泽韦特（Michelle Kiesewetter）在柏林西南350公里处的小镇乌维·魏斯巴赫（Uwe Weisbach）长大。学校毕业后，米歇尔加入了警察部队。她在19岁开始接受训练，完成后加入了德国联邦警察的反恐部队。到22岁时，米歇尔被派往海尔布隆（Heilbronn），这是一个靠近“无脸女子”出没的历史名城。2007年4月，米歇尔·基泽韦特是一名卧底缉毒警官。25日，她正在值班，开着她的绿色
and silver Series 5 BMW Her policing partner, Martin Arnold, was riding in the passenger seat Just before 2pm, the pair stopped for lunch They pulled into a Torezian visa in Heilbronn, an open space used for flea markets and festivals that served as a parking lot when not in use A short time later, witnesses heard multiple gunshots ring out from the parking lot First responders found Michelle lying on the ground outside her BMW She had been shot dead, execution style Martin had also been shot in the face with a bullet lodging behind his right eye He was lucky to survive After waking from a month-long coma, Martin revealed that he couldn't recall anything in the lead-up
和银色5系宝马车。她的警务搭档马丁·阿诺德（Martin Arnold）坐在副驾驶座上。下午2点前不久，两人停下来吃午饭。他们把车开进海尔布隆的一个停车场（Torezian visa），这是一个用于跳蚤市场和节日的开阔空间，不用时用作停车场。不久之后，目击者听到停车场传出多声枪响。急救人员发现米歇尔躺在她的宝马车外面的地上。她被枪杀身亡，死状像行刑一样。马丁的脸部也中枪，一颗子弹卡在他的右眼后面。他很幸运地活了下来。在从长达一个月的昏迷中醒来后，马丁透露他记不清事件前的任何事情
to the attack A special task force titled Special Commission Parking Lot was established to investigate the shooting of the two police members Officers set up a drag net, registering any vehicles within a certain radius of the crime scene in the hope that it would reveal any leads While a forensics team went through Michelle's BMW Both Michelle and Martin's service weapons and handcuffs were missing, presumed stolen by their attacker The bullets fired upon the officers came from two different guns, indicating there were at least two offenders The trajectory of the discharged bullets revealed that the gunman had entered the BMW via the rear doors and shot the officer's point blank from the
袭击事件的经过。一个名为“停车场特别委员会”的特别工作组成立，以调查两名警察的枪击事件。警方设立了严密的搜捕网，登记犯罪现场一定半径内的任何车辆，希望能够找到任何线索。当法医团队仔细检查米歇尔的宝马车时，米歇尔和马丁的配枪和手铐都不见了，推测是被袭击者盗走。向警官开枪的子弹来自两支不同的枪，表明至少有两名罪犯。发射子弹的轨迹表明，枪手从后门进入宝马车，并在后座
back seat It happened so quickly that neither officer had time to draw their own weapons Working on the theory that the crime was an act of revenge on the state police investigated zeroed-in on groups that would harbour such resentment They made inquiries with the local homeless and drug-affected communities, but failed to uncover any leads or rule anything out The chief superintendent of Special Commission Parking Lot conceded It was brutal, apparently random, and with no apparent motive What are we dealing with here? And who is the accomplice?
近距离射击了警察。事情发生得太快，两名警察都没有时间拔出自己的武器。根据该罪行是对国家警察报复的理论，警方进行了调查，重点调查那些怀有这种怨恨的群体。他们向当地的无家可归者和吸毒者群体进行了调查，但未能发现任何线索或排除任何可能性。“停车场特别委员会”的总警司承认：这很残酷，显然是随机的，没有明显的动机。我们在这里处理的是什么？同伙又是谁？
Special Commission Parking Lot received its first major lead in June, two months after the shooting DNA samples taken from the center console and one of the rear arm rests of Michelle Kizaveta's BMW came back with a match The woman without a face had been implicated in yet another murder Following this revelation, police ramped up their search to find the killer, who had earned the new moniker based on her latest crime, the Phantom of Heilbronn A reward of 10,000 euros, which was later increased to 15,000, was offered for any information leading to the identification of the Phantom
“停车场特别委员会”在6月获得了第一条重大线索，距离枪击事件两个月后。从米歇尔·基泽韦特的宝马车中央控制台和其中一个后扶手提取的DNA样本得到了匹配结果。“无脸女子”被牵连进又一起谋杀案中。这一消息传出后，警方加大了搜捕凶手的力度，凶手根据其最新的犯罪行为获得了新的绰号——海尔布隆幽灵。警方悬赏10,000欧元（后来增加到15,000欧元），以获取任何有助于确认幽灵身份的信息。
The gang member who had worked with her previously to carry out a robbery of an electronic store in Mauthausen was interrogated yet again Even with a reward on offer, he remained tight-lipped Leads dried up, and of the 18 homicides investigated by the Heilbronn police in 2007 The murder of Michelle Kizaveta was the only one left unsolved The Phantom of Heilbronn, however, was just getting started DNA from the Phantom of Heilbronn, or the woman without a face, was found four months after the murder of Michelle Kizaveta
曾与她合作在毛特豪森实施电子商店抢劫的帮派成员再次受到审讯。即使有悬赏金，他依然守口如瓶。线索中断了，在海尔布隆警方2007年调查的18起凶杀案中，米歇尔·基泽韦特的谋杀案是唯一没有破案的。然而，“海尔布隆幽灵”才刚刚开始行动。在米歇尔·基泽韦特被谋杀四个月后，“海尔布隆幽灵”（即无脸女子）的DNA再次被发现。
It was located in a shared garden south of Heilbronn, following a series of house break-ins in the area Nothing of major significance was stolen, only a few bottles of beer, some bell peppers, and a bunch of grapes Her DNA was found at other crime scenes, including the theft of a car and commuter, Her DNA was found at other crime scenes, including the theft of a car and commuter equipment from a school in the German town of Zarland,
它在海尔布隆以南的一个共享花园里被发现，此前该地区发生了一系列入室盗窃案。没有偷走什么重大的东西，只有几瓶啤酒、一些甜椒和一串葡萄。她的DNA在其他犯罪现场被发现，包括德国萨兰德（Zarland）镇一所学校的一辆汽车和通勤设备的被盗，
as well as a stolen car from Linz in Austria Anyone else arrested in relation to these crimes refused to name the Phantom On January 30, 2008, three men from the country of Georgia traveled to the German town of Happenheim, 80km northwest of Heilbronn They had planned to buy used cars to transport home for resale Their dead bodies were later fished out of the Rhine River after traveling 25km downstream Two men were quickly apprehended for the murders,
以及奥地利林茨（Linz）的一辆被盗汽车。任何其他因这些罪行被捕的人都拒绝说出幽灵的名字。2008年1月30日，来自格鲁吉亚的三名男子前往距离海尔布隆西北80公里处的德国镇哈彭海姆（Happenheim）。他们原计划购买二手车运回家中转售。在顺流而下25公里后，他们的尸体后来在莱茵河中被捞出。两名男子很快因谋杀罪被捕，
one of whom was working as a police informant As reported in Crime Magazine, the informant had previously been given a station wagon by the local police, which he used to transport the bodies prior to dumping them in the river The station wagon was examined thoroughly The carpet within was stained with the blood of the victims When forensics took swabs of the carpet, they also uncovered the Phantom of Heilbronn's DNA
其中一人当时作为警方线索提供者。据《犯罪杂志》报道，这名线索提供者先前曾被当地警察赠送了一辆旅行车，他用这辆车在将尸体倾倒进河里之前进行了运送。这辆旅行车经过了彻底检查。内部的地毯上沾有受害者的血迹。当法医对地毯进行擦拭采样时，他们还发现了“海尔布隆幽灵”的DNA。
Her accomplices refused to give her up, instead implicating each other as being the killer The chief superintendent overseeing special commission parking lot told the Mirror Publication We are as baffled as everyone else about how her DNA came to be there, but it is one more piece in the mosaic All criminals, no matter how deadly or how clever, all slip up eventually We just hope we catch her before she kills again
她的同伙拒绝供出她，反而互相指责对方是凶手。监督停车场特别委员会的总警司告诉《镜报》出版物：对于她的DNA是如何到那里的，我们和其他所有人一样感到困惑，但这是拼图中的又一块。所有罪犯，无论多么致命或多么聪明，最终都会露出马脚。我们只希望在她再次杀人之前抓到她。
On October 22, 2008, 45-year-old Diana Pavlenko was completing chores in her home in Weinsberg, six kilometers east of Heilbronn After cleaning some dishes, the psychiatric nursing assistant locked up and left her house Four days later, Diana's body was found near the hospital where she worked The Phantom of Heilbronn's DNA was found in Diana's car Co-workers described Diana Pavlenko as someone who was friendly and nice, but also extremely reserved Nobody knew much about her private life,
2008年10月22日，45岁的黛安娜·帕夫连科（Diana Pavlenko）正在她位于海尔布隆以东六公里的魏恩斯贝格（Weinsberg）的家中做家务。洗完一些盘子后，这位精神科护理助理锁好门离开了家。四天后，黛安娜的尸体在她工作的医院附近被发现。在黛安娜的车里发现了“海尔布隆幽灵”的DNA。同事们将黛安娜·帕夫连科描述为一个友好而善良的人，但也极其内向。没有人知道太多关于她私生活的事情，
even though Diana had worked on the same ward for 20 years A neighbour spoke of seeing Diana only when she went on to the balcony to hang out washing Otherwise, she remained indoors, usually with the blinds drawn Diana's murder offered investigators a rare opportunity to narrow in on a suspect They theorised that the Phantom might have been a current or former patient at the hospital where Diana worked The psychiatric ward treated 8,000 patients a year between the ages of 18 and 62 Police interviewed some persons of interest at the facility, but privacy laws prevented them from accessing patient files that might have contained more valuable clues
尽管黛安娜在同一个病房工作了20年。一位邻居说，只有当黛安娜走到阳台上晾衣服时，才能看到她。除此之外，她一直待在室内，通常拉着百叶窗。黛安娜的谋杀案为调查人员提供了一个缩小嫌疑人范围的绝佳机会。他们推测，幽灵可能是黛安娜工作医院的现任或前任病人。该精神病病房每年治疗8,000名年龄在18至62岁之间的病人。警方对该机构的一些相关人员进行了讯问，但隐私法阻止他们获取可能包含更有价值线索的病人档案。
The ward's chief physician was fairly dismissive that a female patient was responsible for the murder of his colleague Quote The connection between the DNA trace and us is a mystery to me I can't explain it all to myself When Diana Pavlenko disappeared, she was off duty for a week During this period, no patient went into hiding At Diana's funeral, a witness noticed a peculiar and somewhat unnerving presence He described, quote, neglected figures at the service
该病房的主治医师对女性患者应对他同事的谋杀负责的说法相当不屑一顾。引述：DNA痕迹与我们之间的联系对我来说是个谜。我自己根本无法解释。当黛安娜·帕夫连科失踪时，她已经休假一周了。在此期间，没有病人潜逃。在黛安娜的葬礼上，一位证人注意到了一种奇特且有些令人不安的存在。他描述了，引述，葬礼上衣衫褴褛的人物。
Unshavened and unkempt men donning parkers that no one knew personally He said they were the type of people that he didn't want to meet in the dark Despite the possible psychiatric ward lead, Diana Pavlenko's murder investigation reached the same conclusion as the others and was soon relegated to the cold case files It seemed as though authorities were always one step behind the phantom, but were unable to catch a break By the end of 2008, the phantom of Heilbronn had been on the run for over 15 years Her DNA was linked to nearly 40 major and minor crimes, ranging from small cases to minor crimes ranging from small burglaries to murder, including that of police officer Michelle Kiesewetter
不刮胡子、不修边幅、穿着无人认识的派克大衣的男人。他说，他们是那种他不想在黑暗中遇到的人。尽管有精神病病房的线索，黛安娜·帕夫连科的谋杀案调查与其他案件得出了相同的结论，并很快被归入悬案档案。当局似乎总是落后幽灵一步，却无法取得突破。到2008年底，“海尔布隆幽灵”已经逃亡了15年多。她的DNA与近40起重大和小型罪行有关，从小型案件到小型罪行，从小偷小摸到谋杀，包括对警察米歇尔·基泽韦特的谋杀。
The phantom's crime spree spread across central Europe, with Germany her most popular location to strike But she had also been linked to over a dozen crimes in Austria, another one of her frequent destinations Officials were left scratching their heads While they had uncovered some leads in her transient lifestyle, drug use and possible psychiatric treatment, there was only one certainty The head of the Upper Austria State Criminal Police claimed The only hypothesis we're going to use is that it has to be a woman Several men had now been arrested in relation to crimes involving the phantom But their involvement was the tip of an iceberg
幽灵的犯罪狂潮蔓延到整个中欧，德国是她最常作案的地点。但她还与奥地利的十多起犯罪活动有关，奥地利是她经常光顾的另一个目的地。官员们对此感到一头雾水。虽然他们在她短暂的生活方式、吸毒和可能的精神治疗方面发现了一些线索，但只有一件事是确定的。上奥地利州刑事警察局局长声称：我们将使用的唯一假设是，这必须是一个女性。现在有几名男子因与幽灵有关的罪行而被捕。但他们的涉案只是冰山一角。
My new strands of male DNA had been uncovered at multiple crime scenes Suggesting the phantom had accomplices from Albania, Croatia, France, Iraq, Poland, Romania, Serbia and Slovakia The same male DNA was never found twice The phantom had a different accomplice for each crime she carried out In an article about the violent fugitive, the Sydney Morning Herald noted The phantom of Hyalbron picks up and discards helpers with the same casual abandon with which she kills Highly regarded Viennese psychiatrist Dr. Kurt Kletzer had profiled many disturbing and dangerous individuals in his time He was quoted in the mirror as saying
在多个犯罪现场发现了新的男性DNA链，这表明幽灵有来自阿尔巴尼亚、克罗地亚、法国、伊拉克、波兰、罗马尼亚、塞尔维亚和斯洛伐克的同伙。同样的男性DNA从未被发现过两次。幽灵在她实施的每起犯罪中都有不同的同伙。维也纳著名的精神病学家库尔特·克莱策尔（Dr. Kurt Kletzer）博士在其职业生涯中曾为许多令人不安和危险的个人做过心理侧写，他在《镜报》中被引述说：
The phantom is able to project an aura of normalcy while being anything but She is compelled to murder to feed her drug habit, thus reducing the victim to the status of a woman These psychopathic traits would have been formed at a very early age I would venture that the police are looking for someone from a damaged home life, perhaps a foster child or orphan A child who was abused or whose carers were addicts What doesn't fit at all is the murder of the policewoman and the attempted killing of her partner Unless they thought that they would have drugs, the act may be seen as the ultimate lashing out at authority By early 2009, 800 suspect women had been DNA tested, but all were ruled out as being the phantom
幽灵能够在表现得一切正常的氛围的同时，却又完全不是那么回事。她被迫通过谋杀来维持她的毒瘾，从而将受害者降低为女人的地位。这些精神病态特征在很小的时候就已经形成。我敢说警方在寻找一个来自受损家庭环境的人，也许是寄养儿童或孤儿。一个遭受虐待或照顾者是瘾君子的孩子。完全不符合逻辑的是谋杀女警官以及谋杀她搭档未遂的事件。除非他们认为自己会有毒品，否则这一行为可能被视为对权威的终极宣泄。到2009年初，已有800名可疑女性接受了DNA检测，但所有人都被排除是幽灵的可能。
The cost of the investigation had reached over 12 million euros The reward for information leading to the identification of the elusive figure was now at 300,000 euros She had become, as the international media dubbed her, Germany's most wanted criminal In March 2009, a badly burnt male corpse was discovered in France along the French-German border Disfigured beyond recognition, French authorities thought that the body belonged to an asylum seeker who had been missing for seven years They attempted to identify the man by matching his fingerprints to those on his asylum application paperwork But his fingers were so burnt that his prints could not be obtained Alternatively, authorities swabbed his asylum seeker paperwork, hoping that minute traces of DNA from his fingertips would still be present on the paper
调查费用已超过1200万欧元。为提供线索以确认这个难以捉摸的身影身份而提供的悬赏金现在达到了30万欧元。正如国际媒体给她的称号那样，她已经成为了德国的头号通缉犯。2009年3月，在法国与德国边境的法国境内发现了一具严重烧焦的男性尸体。面目全非，法国当局认为这具尸体属于一名失踪七年的寻求庇护者。他们试图通过将他的指纹与庇护申请文件上的指纹进行匹配来识别这名男子。但他的手指烧得太厉害，无法获取指纹。或者，当局对他的寻求庇护申请文件进行了擦拭取样，希望指尖上的微量DNA仍然存在于纸上。
They were in luck, the paper contained to DNA, allowing for a comparison to the burnt remains The results were startling, the only DNA extracted from the paperwork was female It was a match to the phantom of Heilbronn Given that the asylum seeker who made the application was definitely male This revelation forced investigators all over Europe to rethink the phantom of Heilbronn case Until this point, they had failed to realize that the answer had been staring them in the face the entire time Hey friends, Kaelin here from Teach Me How To Adults and we talk a lot on our show about how to live your best life While also balancing being a financially responsible human
他们运气不错，纸上含有DNA，允许与烧焦的遗骸进行比对。结果令人震惊，从文件中提取的唯一DNA是女性的。这与“海尔布隆幽灵”相匹配。鉴于提出申请的寻求庇护者绝对是男性，这一发现迫使整个欧洲的调查人员重新思考“海尔布隆幽灵”案。直到这一刻，他们才意识到答案一直以来就直勾勾地盯着他们。嘿，朋友们，我是来自“教你怎么做所有事”的凯琳（Kaelin），我们在节目中经常谈论如何在过上最好生活的同时，平衡好作为一个有财务责任感的人。
So if you've been dreaming of that epic vacation or you want to explore a new city while still keeping your bills at bay Listen up because we've teamed up with airbnb to share some ways on how you can easily become an airbnb host So when we took the big leap into adulthood and bought our first home We purposely looked for a place that we could airbnb whenever we're on vacation Or just if we want to try working out of a different city because we both work from home and we love traveling And it's honestly the perfect way to have the freedom and flexibility to travel or just go wherever you want While giving you that second stream of income and covering your cost while you're away And you don't need a mansion or an entire floor of your home
所以，如果你一直梦想着那场史诗般的假期，或者你想探索一个新的城市，同时还能控制好账单，请听好，因为我们与爱彼迎合作，分享一些如何轻松成为爱彼迎房东的方法。因此，当我们迈出成年人的大步并买下我们的第一套房子时，我们特意寻找了一个地方，以便在我们度假时可以将其在爱彼迎上出租，或者如果我们想尝试在不同的城市办公，因为我们都在家工作并且热爱旅行。这老实说是有自由和灵活性去旅行或去任何你想去的地方的完美方式，同时为你提供第二笔收入来源并在你离开时支付你的费用。你不需要豪宅或家里的整层楼。
It could honestly be as simple as just renting out a spare room or just occasionally doing it if you are traveling for a little bit You could honestly be sitting on an airbnb and not even know it So whether you could use a little extra money to cover some bills or for something a little more fun Your home or spare room might be worth more than you think find out how much at airbnb.ca forward slash host In frickenhausen germany 90 kilometers south of heilbronn is the production plant for griner bio one The bioscience company specializes in the development and production of high quality laboratory products During the period that the phantom of heilbronn was wreaking havoc Griner bio one was busy manufacturing cotton swabs for use in laboratories all over europe
老实说，这可以像出租一间空房或者如果你外出旅行一小会儿时偶尔出租一样简单。你可能正坐在一个爱彼迎房源上甚至自己都不知道。因此，无论你需要一点额外的钱来支付一些账单还是为了更有趣的事情，你的家或空闲的房间可能比你想象的更有价值，访问 airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。在德国弗里克豪森（Frickenhausen），海尔布隆以南90公里处，是格里纳生物一号（Greiner Bio-One）的生产工厂。这家生物科学公司专门从事高质量实验室产品的开发和生产。在“海尔布隆幽灵”肆虐的时期，格里纳生物一号正忙于制造用于全欧洲实验室的棉签。
They were also used by certain police departments to collect a dna at crime scenes A 71 year old woman worked in the griner bio one production plant in germany A long-term employee her job was in the factory packaging the cotton swabs Of eastern european descent This woman was the phantom of heilbronn However, she was completely innocent of any crime Unbeknownst to her and everyone else She had been contaminating the swabs with her own dna
它们也被某些警察部门用于在犯罪现场收集DNA。一名71岁的女性曾在德国格里纳生物一号生产厂工作。作为一名长期雇员，她的工作是在工厂打包棉签。具有东欧血统。这个女人就是“海尔布隆幽灵”。然而，她完全没有参与任何犯罪。在不知情的情况下，她和所有人一样，一直在用她自己的DNA污染棉签。
This discovery was made in 2009 when investigators realized that the phantom of heilbronn's dna Only showed up at crime scenes where the griner bio one cotton swabs were used Crime labs who had used swabs from other sources never had a case attributed to the phantom An investigator explained the contamination to the built newspaper The things were double packaged. We thought they were the Mercedes of cotton swabs The swabs were marketed as being sterile and they were They had been processed to remove all germs fungi and viruses But the process did not destroy dna
这一发现在2009年被揭晓，当时调查人员意识到“海尔布隆幽灵”的DNA只出现在使用格里纳生物一号棉签的犯罪现场。使用其他来源棉签的犯罪实验室从未有过归咎于幽灵的案件。一名调查人员向《图片报》解释了污染情况：这些东西是双层包装的。我们以为它们是棉签中的梅赛德斯。这些棉签作为无菌产品进行营销，它们确实是。它们经过处理，消除了所有细菌、真菌和病毒。但这个过程并没有销毁DNA。
They simply weren't designed for collecting genetic material Hence forensic technicians across three nations had for years found the same dna at scores of crime scenes Because they had brought it there on the sterile swabs they carried Griner bio one international expanded on this They announced that the swabs which were sterilized with ionizing radiation and were sterile for medical purposes Were never certified for use in dna analysis As any existing contamination could not be removed by sterilization The revelation that the phantom of heilbronn was no more than an unsuspecting elderly factory worker
它们根本不是为收集遗传物质而设计的。因此，三个国家的法医技术人员多年来在许多犯罪现场发现了相同的DNA。因为他们用携带的无菌棉签把DNA带到了那里。格里纳生物一号国际公司对此进行了扩展。他们宣布，这些用电离辐射杀菌且用于医疗目的的棉签从未被认证用于DNA分析，因为任何现有的污染都无法通过杀菌去除。“海尔布隆幽灵”不过是一个毫无戒心的老年工厂女工的这一发现，
Proved a huge embarrassment for investigators A member of the berlin association of lawyers told the times that DNA analysis is a perfect tool for identifying traces What we need to avoid is the assumption that the producer of the trace is automatically the culprit DNA evidence on a crime scene says nothing about how it got there There is good reason for not permitting convictions on the basis of dna circumstantial evidence alone Upon learning that the phantom of heilbronn didn't exist Dozens of crimes across europe needed to be reexamined
对调查人员来说是一个巨大的尴尬。柏林律师协会的一名成员告诉《泰晤士报》，DNA分析是识别痕迹的完美工具。我们需要避免的假设是痕迹的制造者自动就是罪犯。犯罪现场的DNA证据并没有说明它是如何到达那里的。有充分的理由不允许仅根据DNA间接证据定罪。在得知“海尔布隆幽灵”并不存在后，欧洲各地的数十起犯罪需要重新审查。
While detectives had been chasing a literal ghost the real perpetrators were getting away with murder In 1963 the american comedy film the pink panther was released It follows the story of a bumbling inspector named Jacques Clousseau As he hunts down a jewel thief known as the phantom before he can get his hands on a priceless diamond called the pink panther The film was an international success and inspired a spin-off cartoon series of the same name Two years after the phantom of heilbronn had been identified The police were still no closer to solving the many murders falsely attributed to her
正当侦探们在追逐一个字面上的幽灵时，真正的罪魁祸首却在逍遥法外。1963年，美国喜剧电影《粉红豹》上映。它讲述了一个名叫雅克·克卢索（Jacques Clousseau）的滑稽督察的故事，他追捕一个被称为“幽灵”的珠宝大盗，在其盗走价值连城的名为“粉红豹”的钻石之前将其抓获。这部电影取得了国际成功，并激发了同名的衍生卡通系列。在“海尔布隆幽灵”被确认身份两年后，警方离破获许多错误归咎于她的谋杀案依然遥遥无期。
Including that of police officer Michelle Kiesewetter In early november 2011 a number of german media outlets received a dvd They placed the disc into a player and a recognizable cartoon character popped up on screen The pink panther As reported in The Guardian the dvd started with the pink panther strolling through an unknown city With the show's iconic music score playing in the background The pink panther then bombs a grocery store Suddenly real news footage taken in 2001 of a shop being bombed in cologne germany flashed on screen
包括谋杀警察米歇尔·基泽韦特。2011年11月初，一些德国媒体收到了一个DVD。他们将光盘放入播放器，屏幕上弹出了一个可识别的卡通角色：粉红豹。据《卫报》报道，DVD以粉红豹在一个未知的城市中漫步开始，伴随着该剧标志性的音乐在背景中播放。然后粉红豹轰炸了一家杂货店。突然，2001年在德国科隆一家商店被炸的真实新闻画面闪现在屏幕上。
The disturbing video continued with the pink panther watching television as horrific images of real murder victims And the associated crime scenes were shown one after the other Just before the conclusion of the dvd the pink panther could be seen reclining in a chair As he watched the media footage from the funeral of police officer Michelle Kiesewetter Then the image of a firearm appeared on screen It was Michelle's service weapon stolen from her by her killer immediately after her murder The dvd ended with an exasperated pink panther pointing to a sign on the screen that featured the words National Socialist Underground
这段令人不安的视频继续播放，粉红豹看着电视，屏幕上接连播放着真实谋杀受害者及其相关犯罪现场的可怕图像。就在DVD结束之前，可以看到粉红豹躺在一张椅子上。当他观看警察米歇尔·基泽韦特葬礼的媒体画面时。接着屏幕上出现了一把枪的图像。那是米歇尔的配枪，在她遇害后立即被凶手从她身上偷走。DVD在一只精疲力竭的粉红豹指向屏幕上印有“国家社会主义地下党”字样的标牌中结束。
Ulva Bernhardt and Ulva Mundtlos grew up in the city of Jena 300 kilometers northeast of Heilbronn As reported in The Guardian, Jena had long been a heartland for those with radical far-right views The youth club where Bernhardt and Mundtlos met as teenagers served as a location where young people could find others with extremist right-wing views When Beato Shaper became a member of the same club, she and Ulva Mundtlos quickly fell in love She and Ulva Mundtlos quickly fell in love On her 19th birthday, Shaper met Ulva Bernhardt and developed strong romantic feelings for him also initiating a love triangle between the group Together the trio founded the neo-nazi terrorist group the National Socialist Underground or NSU
乌尔瓦·伯恩哈特和乌尔瓦·蒙德洛斯在海尔布隆东北300公里的耶拿市长大。据《卫报》报道，长期以来，耶拿一直是极右翼极端主义者的核心地带。伯恩哈特和蒙德洛斯在青少年时期相遇的青年俱乐部，正是年轻人寻找志同道合的极右翼极端主义者的聚集地。当贝娅特·舍佩成为该俱乐部的成员时，她和乌尔瓦·蒙德洛斯很快坠入爱河。在19岁生日那天，舍佩遇到了乌尔瓦·伯恩哈特，并对他也产生了强烈的浪漫情愫，由此在小团体中引发了一段三角恋。这三人最终共同创立了新纳粹恐怖组织“国家社会主义地下党”，简称NSU。
They spent the 90s getting into fights with left-wing groups on the streets Both Bernhardt and Mundtlos shaved their heads and dressed in a tire befitting of the neo-nazi scene at the time As reported in The Guardian, they visited the book-involved concentration camp memorial dressed in homemade SS uniforms And invented a board game in which the winner was the person who had sent the most Jewish people to concentration camps Bernhardt, Mundtlos and Shaper all came from well-respected families Their parents treated their children's interest in neo-naziism as a passing phase But it was far from a hobby It consumed every aspect of the three team's lives
他们把20世纪90年代的时间都花在了在街头与左翼团体斗殴上。伯恩哈特和蒙德洛斯都剃光了头，穿着符合当时新纳粹圈子风格的服装。据《卫报》报道，他们穿着自制的党卫军制服参观了布痕瓦尔德集中营纪念馆，还发明了一种桌游，游戏规则是将把最多犹太人送进集中营的人判定为赢家。伯恩哈特、蒙德洛斯和舍佩都出身于受人尊敬的家庭。他们的父母将孩子对新纳粹主义的兴趣视为一个短暂的阶段，但这远非一种业余爱好——它吞噬了这三人生活的方方面面。
They even worked in a store that sold Nazi paraphernalia under the counter The NSU were just getting started In April 1996, Bernhardt hung a doll torso with the word Jew and a star of David off a motorway bridge Connected to the doll were wires leading to a cardboard box that read, beware of the bomb Although a hoax, Bernhardt's fingerprint was found on the phony bomb device, enabling police to make a quick arrest Bernhardt already had a long rap sheet, including offences for endangerment of road traffic, resistance to a law enforcement officer, extortion dangerous bodily harm, sedition and violation of gun laws Yet he was acquitted for the bomb hoax incident
他们甚至在一家暗地里出售纳粹纪念品的商店工作。NSU当时才刚刚起步。1996年4月，伯恩哈特将一个挂着“犹太人”字样和大卫之星的玩偶躯干悬挂在一条高速公路的桥上。与玩偶相连的是几根电线，通向一个写着“小心炸弹”的纸板箱。尽管这是一场恶作剧，但警方在伪造的爆炸装置上发现了伯恩哈特的指纹，从而使警方得以迅速实施抓捕。伯恩哈特此前有着厚厚的前科，包括危害道路交通罪、袭警、敲诈勒索、危险身体伤害、煽动叛乱以及违反枪支法。然而，他最终被判炸弹恶作剧罪名不成立。
While it could be proven he handled the box, there was nothing to prove he had knowledge of the hoax He was still put away Serving just over two years in juvenile detention for possessing three right-wing extremist CDs he intended to sell This coupled with his criminal history was enough to get him off the streets temporarily Two years later in January 1998 police in Jena received a tip-off and searched Bernhardt's garage Inside they found 1.4 kilograms of TNT enough to cause a major explosion However, by this time, the three members of the NSU Bernhardt, his friend Muntlos, as well as their girlfriend, Chaeper, were already on the run
虽然可以证明他接触过那个盒子，但没有任何证据证明他知晓这是一场恶作剧。不过他仍然被收监，因企图出售三张右翼极端主义CD而在少管所服刑略超两年。这些记录再加上他的犯罪历史，足以让他暂时远离街头。两年后的1998年1月，耶拿警方接到线报，搜查了伯恩哈特的车库。在里面，他们发现了1.4公斤的TNT炸药，足以引发一场大爆炸。然而，此时NSU的三名成员——伯恩哈特、他的朋友蒙德洛斯以及他们的女友舍佩——已经开始了逃亡。
They hid out in an apartment 85 kilometers away and used fake IDs and aliases to avoid recognition While German officials were hunting the phantom of Heilbronn, Bernhardt and Muntlos went on a murderous rampage unrelated to any of the phantom's crimes Harboring an intense hatred for Turkish immigrants, the two men targeted the Turkish population with Chaeper assisting in the planning of the attacks On September 9, 1998, the Turkish authorities began their search for murder On September 9, 2000, they shot and killed a florist as he sat in his work van in Nuremberg Police fabricated a motive for the crime involving the Turkish criminal underworld
他们藏身于85公里外的一处公寓中，使用假身份证和化名来躲避识别。正当德国官员们搜寻“海尔布隆幽灵”时，伯恩哈特和蒙德洛斯却展开了一场与幽灵罪行无关的连环谋杀。这两人对土耳其移民怀有强烈的仇恨，将土耳其族群作为袭击目标，而舍佩则协助策划了这些袭击。1998年9月9日（注：此处应为2000年，根据下文微调或按原文翻译），土耳其当局开始搜寻凶手。2000年9月9日，他们在纽伦堡开枪打死了一名坐在工作货车里的花商。警方为这起犯罪捏造了一个动机，将其归咎于土耳其犯罪黑社会。
Despite the victim's wife denying this theory, police were staunch in their opinion When three more Turkish nationals were found shot dead soon after, the police were certain it was all gang-related Meanwhile, the NSU continued their string of attacks They sent a bomb disguised as a Christmas present to a grocery store owned by a Turkish family When the store owner opened the gift, the bomb detonated Nobody was killed in the blast, but the store owner's daughter was seriously injured Following this, the NSU went underground for three years They resurfaced in February 2004 to kill the manager of a kebab restaurant
尽管受害者的妻子否认了这一理论，但警方依然固执己见。不久之后，当又有三名土耳其国民被枪杀时，警方确信这一切都与黑帮有关。与此同时，NSU继续着他们的袭击系列。他们将一枚伪装成圣诞礼物的炸弹寄给了一家由土耳其家庭拥有的杂货店。当店主打开礼物时，炸弹爆炸了。爆炸中无人死亡，但店主的女儿受了重伤。此后，NSU转入地下潜伏了三年。他们在2004年2月重新露面，杀害了一家烤肉店的经理。
Four months later, they placed the nail bomb on a busy shopping street in Koypstraza, Cologne, an area with a higher Turkish population The blast injured 22 people Over the following two years, three more Turkish men were murdered Police were well aware of the pattern, but were adamant it was an internal conflict Another shooting in June 2006 was believed to be related, but as the victim was of Greek-German heritage, investigators could not be certain All of the shootings committed by the NSU were the same in that they were all done in an execution style manner
四个月后，他们在科隆土耳其人聚居的繁忙商业街科伊普施特拉塞放置了一枚钉子炸弹。爆炸导致22人受伤。在接下来的两年里，又有三名土耳其男子被谋杀。警方很清楚这种模式，但坚信这是一场内部冲突。2006年6月的另一起枪击案被认为与此有关，但由于受害者具有希腊裔德国血统，调查人员无法确定。NSU犯下的所有枪击案都有一个共同点，即它们都是以行刑式的方式进行的。
The victims were shot in the face while looking directly at their killer The firearm used was a CZ-83 semi-automatic pistol Police efforts to narrow in on the offenders were hampered by their ongoing assumption that they were members of the Turkish criminal underworld They maintained this belief, despite evidence of the contrary Two of the murders took place near police stations, something the underworld would avoid at all costs Witnesses reported two men of German or Eastern European appearance fleeing the scenes of the shootings on pushbikes Furthermore, the murders took place when the victims were breaking their regular routine,
受害者在直视凶手的同时面部中枪。使用的火器是一支CZ-83半自动手枪。警方缩小嫌疑人范围的努力受到了持续的假设的阻碍，他们一直认为嫌疑人是土耳其犯罪黑社会的成员。尽管有相反的证据，他们仍然坚持这一信念。其中两起谋杀案发生在警察局附近，这是黑社会无论如何都会避免的事情。目击者报告称，有两名具有德国或东欧外貌的男子骑着自行车逃离枪击现场。此外，谋杀发生时受害者正在打破他们的常规作息，
implying they were opportunistic, not premeditated Although a right-wing terrorist group was briefly suspected by the police, it wasn't until the pink panther DVD emerged when the perpetrators were formally identified as the National Socialist Underground On November 4, 2011, Uwe Bernhardt and Uwe Muntlose donned guerrilla masks and attempted a robbery in the Eastern German city of Eisenach Robberies were the pair's means of funding the NSU Their efforts failed and the pair were forced to flee on their bicycles They took shelter in a caravan Bernhardt had rented, where they'd wait until the heat died down
这意味着这是随机发生的，而非预谋。尽管警方曾短暂怀疑过右翼恐怖组织，但直到粉红豹DVD的出现，凶手才被正式确认为“国家社会主义地下党”。2011年11月4日，乌尔瓦·伯恩哈特和乌尔瓦·蒙德洛斯戴着游击队面具，在德国东部城市艾森纳赫尝试抢劫。抢劫是这两人资助NSU的手段。他们的行动失败了，被迫骑自行车逃跑。他们躲进了一辆伯恩哈特租来的房车里，准备在那里等待风头过去。
The two men were completely unaware that they had been covertly tailed from the scene of the botched robbery to their current whereabouts Upon realizing they were surrounded, Bernhardt and Muntlose made a pact After setting the caravan on fire, Muntlose shot Bernhardt fatally in the head before turning the gun on himself In the remains of the caravan, police uncovered a number of guns including the firearm issued to police officer Michelle Kiesewetter A check of the caravan's registration revealed that it was one of the vehicles identified in the police dragnet shortly after Michelle's murder Beata Chaeper learned of the suicide of both her lovers later that day
这两个人完全没有意识到，他们从拙劣的抢劫现场被秘密尾随到了现在的藏身处。当意识到自己被包围时，伯恩哈特和蒙德洛斯订立了一个盟约。在点燃房车后，蒙德洛斯朝伯恩哈特的头部开枪致其死亡，随后自己也举枪自尽。在房车的残骸中，警方发现了多把枪支，其中包括发给女警米歇尔·基瑟韦特的警用枪支。对房车登记信息的核查显示，它正是米歇尔遇害后不久警方布控网中确定的一辆车辆。贝娅特·舍佩于当天晚些时候得知了她两个情人的自杀消息。
At 3.05pm, she emptied a 10-litre canister of gasoline throughout the apartment the trio used as a hideout Chaeper then made a hasty exit with her two pet cats in cages She also had with her 15 copies of the Pink Panther DVD the group had edited together As she walked away, the apartment wall exploded and flames engulfed the building Chaeper approached a woman walking by and placed the cages containing her cats at her feet She asked the stranger to look after her animals for a minute Chaeper then ran away Inside the wreckage of the apartment, investigators found several newspaper articles about murders committed on Turkish immigrants
下午3点05分，她将一整桶10升的汽油泼在三人当作藏身处的公寓各处。随后，舍佩带着装在笼子里的两只宠物猫仓促撤离。她随身携带的还有他们三人共同剪辑的15份《粉红豹》DVD副本。当她走开时，公寓的墙壁发生了爆炸，大火吞没了整栋建筑。舍佩走到一名路过的女性身边，将装着猫的笼子放在对方的脚边。她请求这位陌生人帮她照看动物一分钟。随后，舍佩逃跑了。在公寓的废墟中，调查人员发现了几篇关于针对土耳其移民谋杀案的报纸文章，
several thousand euros in cash and checks, a CZ pistol, and a pair of handcuffs The handcuffs had belonged to officer Michelle Kiesewetter German authorities were confident that Uwe Bernhardt and Uwe Mutlos were responsible for Michelle Kiesewetter's murder Testing of the CZ pistol revealed it was the murder weapon used in the other nine murders attributed to the NSU Meanwhile, Beata Chaeper was on the run, traversing Germany via the railway system Sometime during her travels, she posted the copies of the Pink Panther DVD to various media outlets The DVD and the confessions from the NSU soon made national headlines November 8, 2011 marked four days after the deaths of Uwe Bernhardt and Uwe Mutlos
数千欧元的现金和支票、一把CZ手枪以及一副手铐。这副手铐属于警官米歇尔·基瑟韦特。德国当局确信乌尔瓦·伯恩哈特和乌尔瓦·蒙德洛斯对米歇尔·基瑟韦特的谋杀负责。对CZ手枪的测试表明，它是归咎于NSU的其他九起谋杀案中使用的凶器。与此同时，贝娅特·舍佩正在逃亡中，通过铁路系统横穿德国。在她的旅程中的某个时候，她将《粉红豹》DVD的副本寄给了各大媒体机构。DVD和NSU的供词很快成为了全国各大媒体的头条新闻。2011年11月8日，标志着乌尔瓦·伯恩哈特和乌尔瓦·蒙德洛斯死亡四天后。
Local police in Jena, where the NSU was founded, received a call When a police officer answered, she was greeted on the line by a female voice Beata Chaeper here, I am the one you're here for The local police department was not aware that Beata Chaeper was wanted for the NSU crimes and the officer terminated the call However, Chaeper soon turned herself in to authorities Beata Chaeper was charged with all the crimes attributed to the NSU This included the shooting murders of the nine Turkish men
NSU发源地耶拿的当地警察局接到了一个电话。当一名女警接听电话时，电话那头传来了一个女人的声音：我是贝娅特·舍佩，我就是你们要找的人。当地警察局并不知道贝娅特·舍佩因NSU的罪行而被通缉，于是这名女警挂断了电话。然而，舍佩不久后便向当局自首了。贝娅特·舍佩被控犯下了归咎于NSU的所有罪行，其中包括枪杀九名土耳其男子的谋杀案。
The two bombings, the attempted murder of Officer Martin Arnold and the murder of his policing partner, Officer Michelle Kizaveta Four men were also charged as accomplices and ordered to stand trial with Chaeper on the grounds of procuring weapons for the NSU and for being accessories to the bombings Of the four men, only one, a former neo-Nazi, showed genuine remorse for his role in the murders The failure of the German police to acknowledge that the spree killings of Turkish nationals could be anything but an internal conflict within the community's criminal underbelly prompted outrage from the public
两次爆炸案、对马丁·阿诺德警官的谋杀未遂以及对其警务搭档米歇尔·基扎韦塔（注：基瑟韦特音译不同）的谋杀。四名男子也被控为同谋，并被命令与舍佩一起出庭受审，罪名是为NSU采购武器以及作为爆炸案的共犯。在这四名男子中，只有一人（前新纳粹分子）对自己在谋杀中所扮演的角色表现出真正的悔意。德国警方未能承认针对土耳其国民的连环杀戮可能是该社群地下犯罪黑社会内部冲突以外的任何事情，这引发了公众的愤怒。
German police were even accused of turning a blind eye to right-wing extremists This level of ignorance enabled the NSU to function unabated for 13 years In response to the criticism, the president of the Federal Intelligence Agency as well as several other high-ranking security officials resigned from their positions The informal title of the investigation into the crimes, the Kabab murders, was also criticized for being deeply offensive to the Turkish community Only two of the victims worked at Kabab shops
德国警方甚至被指控对右翼极端分子视而不见。这种程度的无知使得NSU得以毫无阻碍地运作了13年。为了回应批评，联邦宪法保卫局局长以及其他几位高层安全官员辞去了职务。对这些罪行的非官方调查名称“烤肉店谋杀案”也因对土耳其社群极具攻击性而受到批评。只有两名受害者在烤肉店工作，
and even so, the racial and comical undertones of the name were obvious It did little to depict the seriousness of the crimes and the grief of those impacted causing an overall dismissiveness of the growing threat by the mainstream media and those of other creeds The trial against Biyata Chaper and her four accomplices began in 2013 overseen by a panel of judges only Neo-Nazis packed the courtroom and loitered outside
即便如此，该名称中包含的种族主义和滑稽色彩也是显而易见的。它几乎没有描绘出犯罪的严重性以及受影响者的悲伤，导致主流媒体和其他信仰的人对日益增长的威胁采取了一种整体上轻视的态度。针对比娅塔·舍佩及其四名同谋的审判于2013年开始，由一个法官小组监督。新纳粹分子挤满了法庭并在外面徘徊，
with publication The New Republic commenting that it gave the trial a menacing presence Chaper barely spoke, leaving her attorney to communicate on her behalf through lengthy pre-written statements Those called to give evidence on behalf of the defense attempted to slow proceedings as much as possible Victims families who had hoped for some answers as to why their loved ones had been targeted were left largely in the dark In closing arguments, Biyata Chaper's legal team argued that she had once been a Nazi but had changed her ways shortly after the NSU began their attacks
《新共和国》杂志评论称这给审判带来了一种威慑感。舍佩几乎没有说话，而是让她的律政代表通过冗长的事先写好的声明来代为表达。被传唤为辩护方提供证据的人尽可能地拖延诉讼程序。那些一直希望能为亲人为何成为袭击目标讨个说法的受害者家属却大体上被蒙在鼓里。在结案陈词中，比娅塔·舍佩的法律团队辩称，她曾经是个纳粹分子，但在NSU开始袭击后不久就改过自新了。
Therefore, she was no longer a part of the National Socialist Underground when Uwe Bernhardt and Uwe Muntlose began their crime spree against the Turkish community Rather, she was just their roommate As German law required at least three consenting people to form a group The defense argued that their client could not be held responsible for the actions of two people if she didn't associate with them as a group The prosecution argued that Chaper knew exactly what she was doing and was always an active member of the NSU, stating
因此，当乌尔瓦·伯恩哈特和乌尔瓦·蒙德洛斯开始针对土耳其社群的犯罪狂潮时，她已不再是“国家社会主义地下党”的成员。相反，她只是他们的室友。由于德国法律要求至少有三名同意的人才能组建一个团伙，辩护方辩称，如果他们的当事人并非以团伙身份与这两人交往，就不能对两个人的行为承担责任。检方则辩称，舍佩非常清楚自己在做什么，并且一直是NSU的活跃成员，并指出：
The motive of all these crimes was a far right ideology The fever dream of a country free of foreigners and the intention to shake this free, friendly country in which we live to its core in order to prepare the ground for a disgusting Nazi regime The trial lasted 437 days and involved 73 separate lawyers and hundreds of witnesses All defendants were found guilty Sentences for Chaper's four accomplices ranged from two and a half to 10 years prison Chaper received a life sentence with particular gravity
所有这些犯罪的动机都是极右翼意识形态。这是一个没有外国人的国家的狂热梦想，其意图是动摇我们生活的这个自由、友好的国家的根基，从而为一个令人作呕的纳粹政权做准备。这场审判持续了437天，涉及73名不同的律师和数百名证人。所有被告均被判有罪。舍佩四名同谋的刑期从两年半到十年监禁不等。舍佩被判处终身监禁且情节特别严重，
This means she can apply for parole after serving 15 years jail time but will be unlikely to receive it Although it couldn't be proven that Chaper had been at any of the crime scenes the judges concluded that she was aware of and contributed to the killings that were designed to spread fear and insecurity among immigrant communities Not everyone was convinced that the deaths of Uwe Bernhardt and Uwe Muntlose and the imprisonment of Biata Chaper marked the end of the National Socialist Underground The NSU Watch, an alliance of anti-fascists and anti-racists
这意味着她在服刑15年后可以申请假释，但获批的可能性不大。尽管无法证明舍佩曾出现在任何犯罪现场，但法官得出结论：她知晓并促成了那些旨在在移民社群中散布恐惧和不安的杀戮。并非所有人都确信乌尔瓦·伯恩哈特和乌尔瓦·蒙德洛斯的死以及比娅塔·舍佩的入狱标志着“国家社会主义地下党”的终结。NSU观察组织（一个由反法西斯主义者和反种族主义者组成的联盟），
dedicated to tracking the NSU movement and imparting knowledge about neo-Nazis, commented The court is desperately maintaining that the NSU is a thing of the past that right-wing terrorism no longer exists The results of the main hearings, the inquiry committees and our own research show that the NSU is a network, it still exists and it was not a group of three loners We will persist until the families, the public and we all know the identities of all the NSU supporters
致力于追踪NSU运动并传播有关新纳粹分子的知识，他们评论道：法院拼命坚称NSU已成为过去，右翼恐怖主义已不复存在。主审听证会的结果、调查委员会以及我们自己的研究表明，NSU是一个网络，它仍然存在，而且它并非由三个独行者组成。我们将坚持不懈，直到家属、公众以及我们所有人都知道NSU所有支持者的身份，
and until they've been held accountable We want justice Lawyers for Biata Chaper lodged an appeal which has yet to commence The reason why the NSU targeted police officers Michelle Kizaveta and Martin Arnold remains a mystery The notion that they were targeted for their service weapons or seized drugs although readily accepted in the beginning lost traction over time One other theory has since emerged that helps shed a light on why the offenders stepped out of their typical racially motivated MO and targeted two police officers
并直到他们被追究责任。我们要伸张正义。比娅塔·舍佩的律师提出了上诉，目前尚未开始。NSU将警官米歇尔·基瑟韦特和马丁·阿诺德作为袭击目标的原因仍然是个谜。他们是因为值班武器或被查获的毒品而成为目标的这种观点，虽然在最初很容易被接受，但随着时间推移逐渐失去了动力。此后出现了另一种理论，有助于阐明为什么罪犯会打破他们典型的种族动机作案手法，转而将两名警官作为袭击目标。
Michelle Kizaveta had a cousin named Anya who was also a police officer As reported on the world socialist website in 2014 Anya told a parliamentary committee that her daughter who was Michelle's cousin might have had ties with a neo-nazi group named Blad and Dona Anya also admitted having links to the far right scene in the past including supporters of the NSU She stated that her father who was a police officer and her husband a security officer also had ties to neo-nazi groups The inquiry concluded that perhaps Michelle Kizaveta knew too much about the workings of the NSU
米歇尔·基瑟韦特有一个名叫安妮的表亲，她也是一名警察。据2014年世界社会主义网站报道，安妮告诉议会委员会，她的女儿（即米歇尔的表亲）可能与一个名为“布拉德和唐娜”的新纳粹团伙有联系。安妮还承认过去与极右翼圈子有联系，包括NSU的支持者。她表示，身为警察的父亲和身为保安的丈夫也与新纳粹团伙有联系。调查得出结论，也许米歇尔·基瑟韦特知道太多关于NSU运作内幕的信息。
It was also established that at least two of the 10 authorities including the lead investigator assigned to the Michelle Kizaveta case had once belonged to the white supremacist group the Ku Klux Klan The Ku Klux Klan This prompted speculation that the police were intentionally turning a blind eye to the attacks carried out by the NSU In 2016 an international standard was finalised to minimise the risk of human DNA contamination
调查还确定，被指派负责米歇尔·基瑟韦特案的10个当局部门中，至少有两名（包括首席调查员）曾属于白人至上主义团体“三K党”。三K党。这引发了人们的猜测，即警方在刻意对NSU实施的袭击睁一只眼闭一只眼。2016年，一项国际标准最终确定，旨在将人类DNA污染的风险降到最低，
in products used by authorities to collect forensic material This came about largely due to the errors caused by the phantom of Heilbronn case Known as ISO 18385 the guidelines provided advice to manufacturers, police forces and laboratories worldwide on steps that can be taken to avoid similar incidents from happening in the future Many of the murders attributed to the phantom remain unsolved In July 2016 a man gathering mushrooms in the woodlands near Rota-Herbrun, central Germany found skeletal remains that had been partially uncovered by wild animals They belonged to a nine-year-old girl named Peggy Kanoblock
在当局用于收集法医材料的产品中。这主要是由于“海尔布隆幽灵”案件所导致的错误而促成的。被称为ISO 18385的指南为全球制造商、警察部队和实验室提供了关于采取哪些步骤以避免未来发生类似事件的建议。归咎于该“幽灵”的许多谋杀案至今仍未侦破。2016年7月，一名在德国中部罗塔-黑尔布伦附近的林地里采蘑菇的男子发现了一具骸骨，其部分被野生动物掘出。这属于一名名叫佩吉·卡诺布洛克的九岁女孩，
who went missing 15 years prior while walking home from school DNA samples from a small piece of cloth found at the scene matched those of deceased National Socialist Underground member Ulva Bernhard The finding shocked investigators News publication DW reported that the finding might open a new chapter on the NSU's shocking murder spree The discovery led to the implementation of a special police force tasked with going back through unsolved homicide cases involving children to see if any others could be attributed to Ulva Bernhard and the NSU
她在15年前放学回家的路上失踪。现场发现的一小块布料上的DNA样本与已故“国家社会主义地下党”成员乌尔瓦·伯恩哈特的DNA相匹配。这一发现震惊了调查人员。新闻出版物《德国之声》报道称，这一发现可能会开启NSU令人震惊的连环杀人案的新篇章。这一发现促成了一支特别警察部队的成立，其任务是重新审查涉及儿童的未侦破凶杀案，以查看是否还有其他案件可归咎于乌尔瓦·伯恩哈特和NSU。
A year later investigators concluded that Bernhard had nothing to do with Peggy's death His DNA had been transferred accidentally onto the cloth uncovered at her burial site This occurred via equipment that had previously been used to examine evidence from the burnt out caravan that contained Bernhard's remains This marked yet another DNA contamination blunder despite the lessons learnt in the phantom of Heilbronn incident Arief Sardurch was a survivor of the 2004 nail bomb blast carried out by the National Socialist Underground He is still coming to terms with the attack that seriously wounded his daughter but has since revealed that what he faced in the aftermath was worse than the actual
一年后，调查人员得出结论，伯恩哈特与佩吉的死无关。他的DNA是被意外转移到在她埋葬地点发现的那块布料上的。这是通过以前曾用于检查包含伯恩哈特遗骸的烧毁房车中证据的设备发生的。尽管吸取了“海尔布隆幽灵”事件的教训，这标志着又一次DNA污染失误。阿里夫·萨尔杜尔奇是“国家社会主义地下党”2004年钉子炸弹袭击的幸存者。他仍在努力接受那场严重伤害了他女儿的袭击，但此后透露，他在事后所面临的遭遇比实际的
explosion In an interview with DW, Arief stated I said that I think neo-Nazis were behind the attack The officer then just held his finger to his lips and he didn't seem to want to hear anything more about it Fear became my constant companion I could not even talk to my wife about it until five years later Arief speaks at events about the consequences of racism and xenophobia He continues to spread awareness about the far right terrorist extremists who he believes are still operating today At one conference, a member of the crowd asked
爆炸还要糟糕。在接受《德国之声》采访时，阿里夫表示：我说我认为新纳粹分子是袭击的幕后黑手。然后那名警官只是把手指放在嘴唇上，他似乎不想再听到任何关于它的事情。恐惧成了我挥之不去的伴侣。直到五年后，我甚至无法与妻子谈论此事。阿里夫在各种活动中发表讲话，讲述种族主义和仇外心理的后果。他继续提高人们对极右翼恐怖极端主义者的认识，他认为这些极端主义者至今仍在活动。在一次会议上，人群中的一名成员问
Arief how his family were coping With tears in his eyes, he said I won't stay silent, that I have learnt As long as you say nothing, nothing changes There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
阿里夫他的家人是如何应对的。他眼中含着泪水说：我不会保持沉默，这是我学到的。只要你什么都不说，什么都不会改变。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。